we have representative Marjorie Taylor
green holding up explicit images of
Hunter Biden during a house oversight
Committee hearing so the hearing
featured two IRS whistleblowers who
allege that the president's son received
special treatment during their
investigation into his business dealings
those of you who are regular Watchers of
the show will probably remember that we
talked about this story a few weeks ago
at least the story in reference to the
two IRS whistleblowers who were saying
Hunter was receiving special treatment
the investigation was being slow walked
and every effort was made to ensure that
it wasn't taken care of effectively and
competently Marjorie Taylor green showed
pictures that were leaked from Hunter
Biden's laptop she also alleged that he
purchased a ticket and essentially
brought this woman across state lines
which she argues would be a violation of
the man act which is obviously a massive
allegation and green also alleged that
the president's son used his business to
write off payments to prostitutes
illegally not a very good look
no especially not when you're the
president's son right I mean I think uh
James Palmer pointed this out that the
testimony that we heard today isn't
necessarily going to say anything we
didn't already know although I argue
that it's important to have an official
record of these things uh but rather
these two IRS agents were able to say or
testify to the fact that the doj did
intentionally slow walk their
investigation and treated Hunter the way
no one else would get to be treated we
make special exceptions for him well I
mean I think there are definitely two
standards of Justice in this country
right now amen this is not specific to
Biden and Trump alone I mean there's one
standard for Julian Assange who sits in
a foreign Prison still in Exile I'm
gonna try to see him later this year
another one for Chelsea Manning who is
the government agent who actually leaked
information to him because she's
transgender so now you see one standard
400 Biden a different one for somebody
who has a different last name be it
Trump or otherwise
part of the problem is we have this
bureaucracy the IRS is one example of it
but a bureaucracy that really
abandons the rule of law to decide what
it feels like doing on a given day and
so those two stories between what Marge
Taylor green saying about Hunter Biden
about the testimony of the two IRS
whistleblowers
these are deeply linked they're both
symptoms of a managerial class a
bureaucracy in this country that does
whatever it sees fit and is going to
effectively politically protect
whichever party is actually protecting
them and preserving them and their
existence and right now that's the
Democrat Party so they happen to be
protecting them if that change in the
future they'd protect whoever paid for
their continued existence but that's
exactly what's happening today yeah this
is absolutely nothing new I think some
people who are just waking up to these
things think that it's the first time
any of this has happened I mean this
goes back a very long time but just to
give a specific example 10 years ago I
believe a little longer ago than that we
knew that the IRS was targeting
conservative groups for audits under the
Obama Administration this is something
which has happened numerous times in the
past we also know that there were two
whistleblowers that actually spoke up
about this which I very much appreciate
here and that also lends credibility the
fact that you had two people at the IRS
stepping up and saying something fishy
is going on here so this wasn't one
individual person whose testimony might
have a little bit of a little bit less
credibility but what I'd like to ask you
is if you were elected president what
would you do to dismantle these
bureaucracies and what would you do to
ensure that there weren't two different
tracts within the justice system yes so
I think that a lot of Republicans end up
making a false promise without knowing
that they're making a false promise they
think it's a true promise they'll say
we're going to come in and reform the
bureaucracy yeah good luck it is
impossible yeah right because this is a
beast it's like a creation a monster
unto itself that existed long before we
arrived as somebody who ever got elected
and long after we're gone
and so I'm not going to make that false
promise to say that I can reform that
bureaucracy
but what the president can do is
actually shut it down and I think this
is where you know even Trump who's the
closest we ever got to at least
identifying this problem stop short
because the traditional wisdom is that
there are these things called Civil
Service protections which say that
members of the bureaucracy cannot be
fired
absent some
uh you know extreme finding of
misconduct
actually if you read the rules carefully
it doesn't work that way
the way it works is you can't fire
individuals right you can't have
backlash against you know any one
individual in that bureaucracy at one at
a time
but that's why what I'm bringing to
Washington DC is mass layoffs because
the Civil Service protections do not
apply on their own terms to mass layoffs
and mass layoffs is what we're bringing
to the federal government is I think it
takes somebody who's willing to break
the glass coming in from the outside
without inhibition and I think Trump
brought an element of that I'm
definitely bringing it
but you have to combine that with an
actual understanding of the law in the
Constitution and together that's what
it's going to take to shut this thing
down what concerns me about shutting it
down just like stopping it is getting a
Resurgence of like what they did with
the bath party in Iraq because they went
in there they conquered it and then they
fired them all and then they formed Isis
like these people have connections with
DARPA with Boeing like they are the
military and so like if we fired them
they just start their own secret
government I feel you know I think that
it's it's not a destination right I'm
not saying that we all have a party
there's one Silver Bullet solution and
then we're done
that's how we get to the start line
right we're not even at the start line
right now we're playing a different game
come in with some puppet claiming to be
the elected official sitting on top of
the managerial class that's a different
game I'm talking about how we get to the
start line of at least restoring
political power to the people who are
actually elected by the governed to
actually exercise it so that's the
starting point you're right it's like a
hydraulic pump or like a water balloon
you squeeze it in one place it'll pop up
somewhere else
but at least with acknowledging the
rules of the road being the people who
we elect to run the government are
actually the ones who want to run the
government yeah this manager of
bureaucracy they'll find their own
private sector version of that that
emerges or some quasi governmental
version that emerges even at the
agencies that exist yeah we need to Be
watchful of that but right now we're not
even playing the start line of that game
what would you replace it with
so so it depends on what the it is if
the it is the Department of Education
I'm not going to replace it with
anything amen if the it is the FBI I'm
going to shut it down and I'm not going
to replace it with anything a lot of
those functions are already being
performed by the U.S Marshals by the DEA
the drug enforcement agency and so you
go on down the list that's the reality
there are certain other functions like
you know that you you would say have to
continue to exist in some form say the
nuclear Regulatory Commission I said I
would shut that down because we haven't
had a nuclear power plant built in this
country in 35 some odd years because the
nuclear Regulatory Commission is
fundamentally hostile to it in that case
I think you can't reform the culture of
that agency you have to shut it down but
we'd rebuild from scratch an agency that
was actually committed to a rational
evaluation of the risks and benefits of
a given nuclear power plant so some
cases shut it down it stays shut down
certain cases you shut it down and then
rebuild something skeletal from scratch
to perform the basic function
and then certain other agencies you know
let's talk about the FDA let's talk
about the SEC let's talk about the U.S
federal reserve I'm talking about a 75
layoff of the people who already work
there and that I think will get the job
done how did we get here what made the
American people so willing to have such
an a bloated administrative State yeah
it was a sort of laziness in our culture
it actually started with laziness of the
elected officials right so
initially the way it was supposed to
work was the people who showed up in
Congress and in the U.S Senate they're
supposed to have the actual law making
Authority but also accountability
they started to get a little lazy with
that accountability these bills get into
the specifics of those details that's a
little too hard to deal with
presidents who we elected in the White
House started to similarly get lazy
saying that well you know the budgeting
process I'm supposed to ask Congress for
permission to spend money it's a little
too complicated let me delegate that
down
so it was sort of a dual delegation the
president of the United States started
to get a little lazy Congress started to
get a little lazy they said let's just
create this third-party apparatus three
letter agencies
where we don't actually have to be
accountable for the result because we
can blame it on them if things go badly
but if things go well we're still the
people who the public knows and I think
it they started attracting very
attention-hungry people to those roles
as well that's what created is people
who wanted the glory without the
accountability yeah they shunted the
accountability to a third unspoken class
so the capital is a beautiful building
right but the U.S Department of
Education or the IRS or the FBI these
are drab government buildings nobody
visits that when they visit Washington
DC let's put the real accountability
over there but then the people who
actually said okay we're gonna assume
that position they're not the people who
actually needed the fame or the glory
they're the people who actually needed
the exercise of power and so in a
certain way everyone got what they
needed out of the trade right the people
who were running for elected office
today many of them just want to get
cable news on a given night of the week
well the same principle applied to
actually the people who didn't
necessarily care about getting attention
but just actually wanted to exercise raw
power and so there was a division of
those who got attention that's what they
wanted versus those who got power
because that's what they wanted and that
studied in this new equilibrium of
having this administrative state that
said okay we'll exercise all the power
you guys just get to get to pretend like
you have it and get your dopamine hits
from getting on television or getting
your attention along the way that's a
long story short a big part of what
happened part of what I really
appreciate about that explanation is you
mentioned it just starting with a little
bit of laziness elected representatives
not wanting to do their job to the
fullest and most rigorous possible
extent and essentially abdicating by
trying to delegate to people it
shouldn't have been delicated to or
delegated to in the first place and so
part of what I try to stress and the
thing that I've talked about pretty
frequently on the show is that simply
slipping a device and having a people
who are not aspiring to something higher
in a spiritual and moral sense ends up
creating creating a tangle of problems
that you never would have anticipated
who would have thought at the time that
an elected leader just being a bit lazy
just not wanting to do what he had to do
that day could result in such a massive
and Bloated bureaucratic state to the
point where we ended up having an a duly
elected president being unseated or at
least having an attempt to unseat him
committed against him by the
administrative state
well I mean I think that there is
something deeper going on in our culture
it's probably the deeper explanation to
the question you asked as well
which is that we are all so starved
for purpose
and meaning yeah and identity right now
that you know if you don't bend the need
of the real thing you're going to bend
the need of something right so
you know a lot of us myself included
right get into this habit of complaining
about tyranny in the United States get
about about the
abuse of governmental power but that
trick only works if you have a
population that quietly is hungering to
bend the need to something you don't
pledge allegiance to that flag you're
going to pledge allegiance to something
there's an old saying it goes if you
have a hole the size of God in your
heart and God does not fill it something
else will instead like the Israelites
are lost in the desert Book of Exodus
stuff here what do they what do they say
we want to go back and be ruled by the
Pharaoh yeah
Moses comes down from the Mountaintop
what do they do by the time he's come
back they've already got the golden calf
so
part of this is a culture that sort of
Demands obeisance and when we think
about freedom from the administrative
State or the autocracy of government
we owe ourselves a long hard look in the
mirror and ask ourselves how we achieve
freedom from our own impulse to bend the
knee because we are hungry for a higher
purpose that we're lacking I think
that's the deeper answer to your
question thanks for watching this clip
from the timcast IRL podcast hang out
with us live Monday through Friday at 8
pm and become a member over at
timcast.com for uncensored members only
shows exclusive thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time